voilà c'est l'heure de notre second
débat il nous emmène en Afrique après la
République centrafricaine le Mali l'an
dernier les soldats français quitte le
Burkina Faso poussé dehors par des
gouvernements qui ont appelé les
ministres Wagner les Russes sont-ils les
seuls responsables de ce sentiment
anti-français qu'elles ont été nausées
que ce seront les deux grandes questions
de notre débat avant cela le constat
réalisé par Flora sauvage l'effet domino
après le Mali et la République
centrafricaine l'armée française qui
luttait contre le terrorisme djihadiste
dans le nord du pays a annoncé son
départ du Burkina Faso confronté un
sentiment anti-français nourri par
l'agent au pouvoir
[Musique]
nous sommes le Burkina Faso indépendant
poussé dehors par le pouvoir burkinabé
des soldats français ont un mois pour
payer bagages laissant la place libre à
la Russie le continent africain est
devenu la cible numéro 1 de la stratégie
d'in son ministre des Affaires
étrangères Sergueï la broche a promis un
engagement intensifié lors d'une visite
qualifiée d'historique par le pouvoir
malien
et la Russie répond de façon efficace
au besoin du Mali en terme de
renforcement des capacités de nos forces
de défense et de sécurité après les
mercenaires russes de Wagner qui
évolueraient dans l'ombre sur le sol
africain depuis plusieurs mois déjà la
Russie affiche désormais ses ambitions
au grand jour et tendre son influence
dans tous les pays de la région en
luttant contre les djihadistes la lutte
contre le terrorisme est bien sûr
d'actualité pour les autres pays de la
région nous allons leur apporter notre
assistance pour surmonter ces
difficultés cela concerne la Guinée le
Burkina Faso et le Tchad et en général
la région sail au saharienne et même les
pays riverains du Golfe de Guinée si le
divorce est consommé entre la France et
une partie de la jeunesse africaine les
visées de du coup vont au-delà de
l'Afrique francophone à l'heure de la
guerre en Ukraine la Russie cherche
ainsi à briser son isolement sur la
scène internationale
quelles sont les racines de ce sentiment
anti-français en en débat tout de suite
avec niagali Bagayoko bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes politologue spécialiste des
questions de défense et de sécurité en
Afrique francophone et présidente de
l'africaine security secteur network
Christian Campbon bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi sénateurs du Val-de-Marne et
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées Vincent Huger bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous grand reporter
essayiste enseignant à Sciences Po et je
cite votre livre tirant d'Afrique les
mystères du despotisme postes colonial
Mathilde Siro était évidemment resté à
mes côtés question assez générale tiens
pour commencer on va avoir le temps
ensuite de détailler la Bagayoko comment
vous expliquer ce je vais dire ce
désamour c'est quoi la première région
vous diriez quoi le terme est rarement
le foyer mais je le trouve assez juste
en réalité
moi il me semble qu'il y a trois raisons
majeures à ce à quoi on assiste
aujourd'hui la première c'est la
déception
qu'a suscité l'incapacité qui a été
celle de l'opération barkhane à venir à
bout de la progression des groupes
djihadistes qui n'ont cessé et qui
continuent de s'étendre et la sorte
d'oubli que l'on a constaté de la part
des autorités françaises qui ont affirmé
leur capacité à neutraliser cet ennemi
déception
marcane la deuxième je pense que l'on a
aussi à faire un rejet d'une certaine
arrogance qui est reprochée à la
diplomatie française et assez plus haute
autorités et la troisième c'est le deux
poids de mesure que l'on constate qui
fait qu'il est devenu absolument
insupportable de voir d'un côté une
jointe au pouvoir au Tchad arrivée à la
faveur d'un changement incons
traditionnel de régime qui plus est avec
à sa tête le fils du président décédé
donc une transition dynastique qui
s'oppose à la fermeté à la fin de
non-recevoir opposés par exemple au
régime pucciste malien alors on va
évidemment reprendre certains de ces
arguments peut-être barkham pour
commencer Christian comment est-ce que
vous dites vous aussi que barkham c'est
un échec
je n'irai pas jusque là d'abord en
mémoire des
qui ont perdu la vie pour sauvegarder la
sécurité de cet état déjà je pense que
on ne doit pas l'oublier je pense qu'il
faut regarder les choses de près Serval
a été un succès Serval a été un succès
et je crois personnellement que ce genre
d'opération ne doit pas trop s'étendre
dans le temps le fait d'être resté 8 ans
présent me semble certainement un peu
trop long car les contingents français
les forces françaises sont arrivées en
libérateur et son parti en occupant et
donc je pense que c'est la durée qui
donne ce sens et c'est la durée parce
que
on a peut-être pas su jumeler cela avec
un autre chapitre sur lequel moi je
souhaiterais revenir quelle aide au
développement on en parlera évidemment
au fur et à mesure que l'on sécurisé des
zones peut-être
aurions-nous dû avoir de véritables
brigades du développement qui aurait
rouvert l'école les centres de santé etc
et je crois que c'est un peu trop long
vous savez il y avait un général qui
était venu devant la commission qui
avait dit les Opex c'est comme une
autoroute le problème c'est de savoir à
quelle sortie on prend peut-être qu'on a
un peu trop tardé à sortir en deux mots
on rappelle ce que ce que sont ce qui
était ces opérations militaires qui sont
enchaînées et l'objectif donc l'objectif
est radicatif ou en tout cas bloquer la
progression de djihadiste dans un
premier temps donc l'opération Serval
sous François Hollande consiste à la
demande des autorités maliennes
d'entraver la progression d'une alliance
djihadisto touareg dans un premier temps
on est très vite la composante Touareg
sera évincée par la mouvance djihadiste
progression vers le centre puis le cassé
chez an vers le sud de pays et la
capitale Bamako c'était donc une
opération qui était circonscrite dans le
temps et dans l'espace ensuite et pour
en avoir discuté avec des stratèges de
l'armée française des off qui est engagé
sur le terrain
il y a une loi des reins quasiment
inexorable c'est que lorsque vous avez
l'extension du domaine de la lutte pour
être au LB qui indique seconde que on
vient dans un format immense sur 5 pays
5 millions de kilomètres carrés etc et
on s'installe aussi dans la durée donc
ça c'est les officiers donc on passe à
barkhane été 2014 les officiers avec qui
j'ai eu l'occasion d'en discuter souvent
me disent quoi qu'il advienne et c'est
d'ailleurs la conviction de François
Lecointre le chef d'état-major des
armées de l'époque quoi qu'il advienne
même si une force étrangère et là à
l'invitation d'un pouvoir réputé
légitime lorsque vous inscrivez dans le
temps long vous êtes vécu comme une
force d'occupation donc le regard
critique dans le retour d'expérience
pour rester dans la Vulgate militaire il
venait des militaires eux-mêmes il y
avait quelque chose d'inévitable surtout
est-ce que l'objectif pardon est-ce que
l'objectif était tenable ou réaliste
surtout quand la force en question émane
de l'ancienne puissance coloniale ce qui
ouvre un boulevard à toute la rhétorique
anti impérialiste etc sur laquelle on
verra souvent alors sur votre question
précise Thomas je pense que en une
formule le dispositif barkham s'est
acquitté non sans bravoure d'une mission
impossible impossible du fait de la
nature même de la conflictualité vous
savez dans la frustration qui évoquait
niagalée dans son triptyque introductif
tout à l'heure
c'est un temps frustration éprouvé par
les peuples sahéliens par rapport à
l'impuissance en tout cas minimale un
succès de cette opération comment se
fait-il que la cinquième ou sixième
argument soit incapable de il y a un
angle mort c'est que c'est une
conflictualité nouvelle dans laquelle la
suprématie technologique ne vous donne
pas davantage décisif pourquoi parce que
vous êtes fait face à des adversaires
mobiles en effectif limité qui ont une
connaissance parfaite de la topographie
qui est un atout considère dès le départ
finalement
cette double mission elle était elle
était entre guillemets le terme que j'ai
en tête est pas joli mais pourri de
l'intérieur enfin vous voyez le
l'objectif était une atteignable échec
merci oui parce que je rejoins tout à
fait Vincent il y a eu une incapacité
qui n'est pas uniquement celle de la
France il est extrêmement important de
le rappeler il y a un échec collectif à
la fois de tous les acteurs
internationaux mais aussi des états
sahéliens eux-mêmes à mesurer à la
possibilité de de côté français ou côté
partenaire international oui je pense
qu'on y a cru de manière très sincère
mais il y a eu dès le départ une
déconnexion des objectifs politiques et
des objectifs militaires c'est à dire
qu'on a fait de l'instrument militaire
le faire de lance de la politique menée
l'instrument militaire est un outil ce
n'est pas ça ne peut pas guider une
politique il faut avoir une vision de la
solution et c'est là aussi qu'il y a eu
un gros problème juste pour très
rapidement c'est dans la divergence de
vision stratégique avec des partenaires
sahéliens qui encore aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs au Niger très connu le
recours parallèle à la négociation avec
les groupes djihadistes ce à quoi la
France est opposée de manière absolument
non négociable Christian comment vous
êtes d'accord avec cette idée c'est que
l'objectif politique a pris le dessus
sur la réalité militaire la réalité
militaire déjà elle était elle était
hors de portée avec 5500 soldats
contrôlés une étendue de territoire
grande comme l'Europe
vous avez beau mettre beaucoup de
technologie et beaucoup de dévouement et
de ces si nos forces en ont mis vous ne
pouvez pas y arriver je pense que le
problème qui est évoqué est tout à fait
réel c'est-à-dire qui illus que dans le
même temps les autorités politiques
acceptent d'entrer dans une opération
dans laquelle la France jouait son rôle
mais il fallait effectivement un peu de
politique je rappelle qu'il y avait des
Accords d'Alger
qu'en Algérie qui n'ont globalement pas
été appliqués et qui prévoyait
effectivement un certain nombre de
dispositions qui devaient permettre de
retrouver la paix politique c'est-à-dire
mettre autour de la table celles et ceux
ceux qui renonçaient à la violence et
qui voulaient effectivement discuter de
l'avenir du Mali ça n'a pas été possible
et on le sait il y a eu des lâcheté il y
a eu un manque de volonté on a dit très
longtemps qu'il n'y avait plus d'État au
Mali notamment dans la partie santé dans
la partie sud la partie nord était
partie depuis longtemps de mon point de
vue et donc à partir de ce moment-là les
populations voient le résultat et on
peut comprendre quelque part qu'elles
envoient à la France aux Européens et à
ceux et il faudra aussi parler du rôle
de la minussement qui n'est pas qui a
joué un rôle assez ambigu au sens où la
mission qu'il aurait été confiée était
une mission qui visait à renforcer la
paix mais il y avait pas la paix donc
ils étaient plutôt cantonnés avec
peu de moyens et beaucoup de difficultés
matérielles je on va faire un bilan de
la présence française des soldats
français en Afrique aujourd'hui environ
6000 soldats français en Afrique on va
voir la liste des pays et du nombre de
soldats s'afficher sur sur cette carte
de la Côte d'Ivoire avec 900 militaires
en passant par le chat le Niger le
Sénégal le Gabon le Golf de Guinée ou
encore Djibouti avec 1500 soldats
Vincent Huger est-ce que donc les les
soldats français doivent quitter le
Burkina Faso avant la fin du mois c'est
le troisième pays on est dans un
processus qui se répète est-ce que c'est
un processus inexorable pour moi le
retrait la réduction de voilure de la
présence militaire française en Afrique
est inéluctable et inexorable on est
entré dans une phase où il s'agit non
plus de redéploiement consenti
ou penser mais de retraite subie c'est à
dire que la France n'apprime pas la
dynamique vous avez c'est la
souveraineté de tout état la possibilité
de négocier renégocier voire dénoncer
des accords de coopération militaire
mais ça se fait dans des formes
relativement ritualisées là il s'agit
pas de ça là il s'agit de répondre à des
sommes nations deux pays souverains qui
pour de bonnes ou de mauvaises raisons
on pourra y revenir décide que la
prévention française est non seulement
contre-productive mais néfaste vous ne
pouvez pas surtout encore une fois quand
vous traînez les arriérés coloniaux
imposer par la force votre présence dans
des pays qui ne veulent pas de vous on
n'est plus dans la période faux
cartienne référence à Jacques focard le
marabout africain de la France gaulise
décidé que vous allez sauver un chef
d'État à bout de souffle illégitime en
prétextant évidemment de voler au
secours des populations européennes et
ça ça contribue deuxième volet du
triptyque de Niaga les bakay tout à
l'heure ça contribue évidemment parce
qu'il faut toujours s'astreindre à
penser contre soi-même et balayer devant
sa porte à l'incroyable impopularité de
la France officielle dont on se souvient
dans les genèses africaines
d'aujourd'hui qu'elle sait si souvent
portée au secours deux régimes
indéfendable
bien élu mal élu et très souvent pas élu
du alors c'est ce cas et quelques
successeurs c'est ce qu'on appelle la
France africaine est-ce que c'est la fin
de la France Afrique à laquelle on
assiste
a tellement été annoncé
des années moi je pense que c'est encore
à autre chose que l'on assiste c'est une
redéfinition des relations de l'Afrique
avec le reste du monde c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il y a de manière très
nette chez la plupart des dirigeants
africains la volonté de multiplier les
partenariats au-delà des relations
bilatérales entretenues par les
différents partenaires si on prend un
état comme le Niger c'est très
intéressant pardon j'explique ce que je
vous dis très intéressant puisque le
Niger est aujourd'hui le principal
partenaire de la France puisque la
plupart des effectifs de la défunte
opération barkhane se trouve aujourd'hui
sur le territoire du Niger il est
possible qu'ils accueillent également
certains des effectifs de l'opération
sabre depuis le Burkina Faso mais le
principal partenaire du Niger en matière
de vente d'armes c'est la Russie et le
deuxième c'est la Turquie et donc la
France accepte de ne plus être le
partenaire privilégié en quelque sorte
d'arriver à démontrer sa valeur ajoutée
dans ce paysage qui n'est pas uniquement
composé de compétiteurs mais aussi de
compétiteurs parce que je pense qu'on
aurait tort de trop continuer à se
focaliser sur la Russie il y a
aujourd'hui de très nombreux autres
acteurs que ce soit Israël que ce soit
les États-Unis que ce soit l'Inde ou que
ce soit les acteurs européens
bien on va on consacrer un chapitre de
ce de ce débat à la Russie au fameux
milice Wagner mais Mathilde je voudrais
qu'on fasse un focus maintenant sur
finalement le l'action la politique du
du président français Emmanuel Macron en
2017 donc on est au début de son premier
quinquennat évidemment il déclare il est
à Ouagadougou il n'y a plus de politique
africaine de la France et pourtant ça
peut sembler un paradoxe mais c'est sous
son mandat que ce sentiment finalement
anti-français se développe oui le
président veut réinventer c'est son
c'est son mot le partenariat avec le
continent africain alors vaste programme
on ne peut pas lui faire le reproche de
ne pas avoir tenté d'ouvrir des
chantiers des questionnements qui sont
particulièrement sensibles et difficiles
on pense bien sûr à la mémoire avec le
Rwanda l'Algérie ou encore le Cameroun
au sein de l'exécutif on dit dorénavant
que le président veut revoir l'agenda
africain pas seulement d'un point de vue
militaire évidemment mais aussi
diplomatique et sur le plan du
développement on y reviendra la nouvelle
doctrine de l'armée qui se met en place
notamment au Niger vous en avez parlé
aussi en Côte d'Ivoire plus question de
faire à la place des soldats locaux mais
avec eux à leur côté qu'est-ce qu'on
sait est-ce qu'on sait dos avec son à
d'autres informations pardon sur cette
nouvelle feuille de route africaine
alors c'est assez nébuleux pour
l'instant ce qu'on peut déjà noter
Thomas c'est que la volonté du Président
c'est de diversifier ses liens en
Afrique d'aller chercher de nouveaux
points d'appui c'est à dire de ne plus
seulement se concentrer sur en gros le
Maghreb et le Sahel l'Afrique c'est
évidemment des ressources naturelles un
quart de la population mondiale en 2030
et donc un vaste marché autant
d'arguments qui poussent en faveur
évidemment d'une du maintien d'une
coopération étroite je vous résume
l'état d'esprit autour du président on
doit aller à fond avec les pays qui
veulent de nous et laisser ceux qui ne
nous veulent plus c'est pour cette
raison qu'après une première tournée en
juillet qu'il a mené au Cameroun au
Bénin en Guinée Emmanuel Macron va
s'envoler début mars la visite n'est pas
encore totalement officielle
pour des pays qui ne font pas forcément
partie de la zone d'influence naturelle
de la France on pense notamment à
l'Angola un pays qui n'est non
francophone et le deuxième exportateur
de pétrole d'Afrique subsaharienne où il
se rendra pour la première fois
l'Afrique centrale c'est donc au cœur de
cette nouvelle stratégie il ira aussi au
Gabon pays qui vient de rejoindre le
Commonwealth en République démocratique
du Congo qui n'a pas condamné l'invasion
russe à l'ONU tandis qu'après la crise
des visas et l'affaire Pegasus du nom du
logiciel d'espionnage on s'en souvient
la visite qui était prévue en ce début
d'année avec le Maroc elle n'est
toujours pas programmée merci Mathilde
retiens cette phrase que vous avez
glanée avec vos contacts on doit état
d'esprit autour du président on doit
aller à fond avec les pays qui veulent
de nous et laisser ceux qui ne nous
veulent plus Christian Cambot est-ce que
c'est la finalement la bonne attitude
face à cette situation que l'on que l'on
décrit depuis le début de ce débat je
crois effectivement que il est
nécessaire de réexaminer d'une manière
générale le rôle de la France en Afrique
et tenir compte de ces réalités qui ont
été évoquées qui sont incontesta et
savoir effectivement se tourner vers des
pays qui souhaitent
la présence de la France présence qui
n'est plus dans l'esprit de la France
Afrique et qui peut être une présence en
termes de coopération moi j'ai
accompagné le président de la République
au Kenya et en Éthiopie croyez moi on a
reçu un accueil d'autant plus chaleureux
qu'il n'y avait pas eu un chef d'État
français au Kenya depuis 1963 alors donc
ce voyage avait été plein plein
d'espérance encore du reste faut-il
lorsque l'on lance l'idée d'un
partenariat avec ces pays que j'allais
dire il faut que ça suive après et que
véritablement notre présence soit pas
simplement symbolique mais vis-à-vis des
pays qui ne nous souhaitent plus moi je
crois qu'on est tous d'accord pour dire
il n'est pas question de se maintenir
peut-être aurait-on pu voir les choses
la réalité arriver un petit peu avant
parce que quand même le coup d'État dans
le coup d'État à Bamako
je suis pas certain qu'on ait vu cela
avec suffisamment de recul et la même
chose pour le Burkina moi je souhaite du
reste erreur des services peut-être
erreur ou peut-être insuffisance
définitif insuffisance de moyens parce
que je pense que la France ne peut plus
considérer qu'elle est dans son pré
carré et il faut y mettre les moyens
comme d'autres pays où ça a été évoqué
investissent en Afrique investi sur le
plan économique sur le plan culturel
nous avons encore un potentiel
extraordinaire sur place aussi parler du
Maghreb quand même où nous sommes encore
heureusement assez présent il y a quand
même un rôle de la France dans ces pays
et c'est à nous effectivement et
peut-être en consultant le Parlement car
je suis désolé de dire que les débats
concernant la politique en Afrique il
date déjà d'un certain temps et donc je
pense qu'il faudrait revenir devant le
Parlement pour essayer de valider en
quelque sorte ses hypothèses et voir
quel rôle on peut avoir sur le plan
culturel sur le plan économique où nous
il y a des intérêts très importants et
puis voir de quelle aide ces pays
ont-ils besoin pour leur sécurité et
leurs défenses Vincent du jeu est-ce que
là on continue de d'explorer ce
sentiment anti-français il y a eu des
erreurs diplomatiques aussi qui explique
il se trouve que j'étais à Ouagadougou
lorsque
président Macron a prononcé cette phrase
la France n'a plus de politique
africaine ma réaction spontanée a dit
mais quel dommage le problème n'est pas
de ne plus en avoir le problème est dans
la construire une autre et d'aller
au-delà de la rhétorique de tous les
prénoms de la 5e République ou à peu
près au début de leur mandat nous
tournons la page nous enterrons la
France Afrique sans fleur ni couronne
etc bon ensuite bon c'est comme la
guerre un diplomatie c'est un art tout
d'exécution le problème pour revenir aux
erreurs c'est que le en même temps
diplomatie ça ne marche pas et que vous
avez eu des messages contradictoires qui
ont rendu la posture française illisible
on évoquait le Tchad je n'y reviens pas
simplement pour rappeler que Macron a
été le seul chef d'État
occidental à se précipiter à Djamena
était perçu comme quelqu'un qui était
venu adouber une succession kaki
dynastique problème et puis on évoquait
les très bien ouvrir sur le champ
anglophone l'usophone formidable sortir
du prêt carré merveilleux ou va-t-il
dans quelques semaines au Gabon et au
concours
de ce que l'Afrique centrale a produit
de pire en ce qui concerne le mépris du
suffrage universel et des droits humains
donc tout ça rend la posture française
un déchiffrable d'autres erreurs je fais
très vite là-dessus on essaye après les
invectives échangées avec le Mali et qui
serait franchement le discours des
officiels de Bamako avec quelque chose
de détestable dans son côté vindicatif
Jean-Yves Le Drian à l'époque aux
Affaires étrangères Florence Parly aux
armées n'avaient pas besoin de
s'exprimer sur le même registre prendre
un peu de hauteur des règles absolument
et au même moment on dit on va essayer
de limiter la casse avec le Burkina qui
est aussi le théâtre d'un putsch
militaire à double détente d'ailleurs
bon et bien qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
envoie une secrétaire d'État sans doute
estimable mais connu de sa seule famille
crisola zacaro Polo qui est chargé en
plus de la Francophonie et du
développement comment voulez-vous que ce
soit perçu par des régimes suspicieux si
on veut éviter de casser la baraque on
envoie un minima le chef du livre le
plus Bassis ou pour parler des questions
sécurité et militaires le ministre des
Armées si vous voulez donc il y a comme
ça mais je termine sur une autre erreur
parce que elle est peut-être fondatrice
au début 2012 2013 la France est perçue
non sans raison au nord du Mali comme la
force qui empêche l'armée malienne de se
redéployer dans le nord du pays et Dieu
sait que les relations entre le Sud et
le Nord ont toujours été conflictuel et
équivoque et donc on est encore là
dessus aujourd'hui quand vous discutez
avec des intellectuels maliens avec des
politique la France dès cette installa
apparaît comme la complice de ceux qui
ont été les idiots utiles de
l'entreprise djihadiste et c'est de là
que naissent toutes ces vidéos
délirantes toutes ces imputations
fantaisies sur une complicité entre la
France officielle et les fanas du Jihad
alors quand même été bien orchestré
alors
l'armée française ne s'est jamais on va
y venir jamais opposé à l'intervention
de l'armée malienne bien au contraire on
a tout fait pour tenter de les former le
UTM y compris avec des partenaires
européens a fait beaucoup d'efforts
enfin il faut quand même rappeler les
les choses on va y venir à cette à cette
campagne et notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux grâce à Tam traduis qui doit
être juste derrière le rideau rebonsoir
table bienvenue une nouvelle fois donc
la France attaquée dans certains pays
d'Afrique via justement ces réseaux
sociaux oui je vous propose d'ailleurs
tout de suite de regarder un petit film
qui circule sur les réseaux et qui est
destiné à un public africain il circule
depuis un peu plus de 15 jours
maintenant
[Musique]
maintenant c'est notre pays
[Applaudissements]
ils sont nombreux je n'ai plus de
munitions
[Musique]
voilà la France représentée par une
armée de squelettes les démons de Macron
qui vient donc envahir le Mali
représenté par un brave soldat malien
bien seul jusqu'à ce qu'un milicien
russe de Wagner lui viennent en aide
pour pulvériser l'armée d'occupation
c'est ce qu'on vient de voir on voit la
scène aussi dans la suite du film se
reproduire au Burkina Faso ou la France
est représentée sous la forme d'un
serpent bleu blanc rouge et puis en Côte
d'Ivoire et la vidéo se termine par ces
mots à bas l'impérialisme à bas la
France alors sait-on qui a fait cette
vidéo et puis avec quels objectifs alors
les gentils russes de Wagner contre les
méchants français néocolonialistes on
serait tenter de désigné tout de suite
Wagner cette société de mercenaire russe
très actif en Afrique et en Ukraine on
en a pas la preuve formelle ce que l'on
peut dire c'est qu'il y a aussi d'autres
vidéos du même acabit qui ont circulé
ces derniers mois par exemple une qui
représente on la voit et bien Emmanuel
Macron c'est un rat qui grossit qui
vient s'installer dans la cuisine de cet
homme africain jusqu'à ce qu'il appelle
là encore le super dératiseur Wagner et
le rat Emmanuel Macron finit à la fin du
film cuit à la broche à chaque fois et
bien le message c'est sûr il ne fait pas
dans la dentelle il présente la France
comme une puissance
néo-colonialiste qui veut piller
l'Afrique et assez ravir les Africains
ses vidéos bien sûr ne font pas basculer
l'opinion d'une population vous l'avez
très bien expliqué mais elles viennent
souffler sur les braises du sentiment
anti-français aujourd'hui très présent
en Afrique de l'Ouest au Mali au Burkina
Faso au Niger la réaction de la France
est un sujet qui Emmanuel Macron a
ouvertement à bordé notamment lors de
son discours des ambassadeurs c'était au
mois de septembre dernier écoutez
l'autre pays est souvent attaqué il est
attaqué dans les opinions publiques par
les réseaux sociaux et des manipulations
le continent africain on est le meilleur
laboratoire c'est parce qu'on aura une
vraie politique partenariale qui passe
par la culture le sport qui valorise nos
diaspora qu'on enlèvera si je puis dire
les sous-jacents du narratif russe
chinois ou turc qui vient leur expliquer
que la France est un pays qui fait de la
néo-colonisation et qui installe son
armée sur leur sol et face à cela
Emmanuel Macron a appelé à être plus
agressif il a appelé à la mobilisation
générale qui concrètement est passé par
la création d'un poste d'ambassadeurs
pour la diplomatie publique en Afrique
par la mise en place au Quai d'Orsay
d'une cellule de 20 personnes qui est
chargée de la veille et de l'analyse des
réseaux sociaux sachant qu'il y a aussi
une équipe chargée de la riposte au
niveau de l'armée la France a déjà
répliqué en démontant des fake news à
l'opération la plus connue la plus
réussie à ce jour et celle du charnier
de Gossip au Mali en avril 2022 l'armée
française a publié une vidéo on la voit
où elle explique montrer les miliciens
russes enterrants des corps près de la
base de Gossip de l'opération plus pour
la France faire croire à un charnier
laisser parler les soldats français
après la fin de l'opération barkhane
merci Tam Christian comment se cette
cellule à 20 personnes chargée de la
veille de l'analyse des réseaux sociaux
il y a une équipe chargée de la riposte
au sein de l'armée bon c'est bien c'est
mais ça semble un peu
ridicule pardon mais par rapport à
l'ampleur du défi non non c'est déjà une
prise de conscience c'est déjà une prise
de conscience il est évident que la
nomination d'un ambassadeur chargé de la
réplique bon c'est pas ça qui va changer
le cours des choses je pense encore une
fois que un examen approfondi doit la
France doit le mettre en oeuvre et puis
rappeler quand même ce que la France a
fait je rappelle que le Mali tout
d'abord depuis que les Français sont
partis les attentats continuent il y a
eu encore une vingtaine de morts au Mali
il y en a eu 50 au Burkina Faso le mois
dernier donc il faut pas laisser à
croire l'idée selon laquelle c'est la
France qui qui est facteur d'insécurité
car malheureusement le problème demeure
par ailleurs on voit bien que c'est
c'est provocations organisées très
vraisemblablement par Wagner
veulent démontrer qu'une autre puissance
en l'occurrence la Russie souhaite
prendre la place de la France en Afrique
et comme ça a été dit il n'y a pas
simplement que la Russie je comprends
très bien que l'Afrique qui va devenir
un continent de 2 milliards d'habitants
qui est en pleine mutation et c'est
peut-être là où durait sous la France
devrait regarder les choses il faudrait
que l'on comprenne que que l'Afrique est
en train d'évoluer que il y a des gens
qui sont qui deviennent tout à fait
experts dans l'intelligence artificielle
et quand on en Afrique il y a des gens
qui il y a des Africains et des
dirigeants africains qui comprennent
bien comment on peut effectivement aller
dans le sens du développement et ça
peut-être que il y a un changement de
mentalité qui est nécessaire bon je
pense pas que le Président de la
République puisse être soupçonné de
vouloir réinstaller la France Afrique
mais il faut un examen de conscience
approfondie pour voir notamment sur le
plan culturel et économique qui me
semble des sujets très importants sur le
plan du développement vous diriez qu'il
y a des failles par exemple que l'Agence
française de développement ça
dysfonctionne aujourd'hui alors je vais
pas étant le étant le tuteur
parlementaire au Sénat de la FD je vais
simplement rappeler ce que nous
demandons en permanence nous nous sommes
beaucoup battus notamment à travers la
loi cadre sur l'aide au développement
que les 19 pays prioritaires soient
véritablement prioritaire au sein de la
FD il y a des sommes considérables qui
ont été investis vous savez dans le
bassin du fleuve Niger ce sont des
milliards des milliards qui ont été
investis où tout cet argent est passé
a-t-on été nous nous les Français et les
Européens et les pays qui ont dit
suffisamment efficace et moi je pense
personnellement qu'une des erreurs de
barkhane ça a été le fait que au moment
où on sécurisait des zones sur le plan
militaire on aurait dû avoir de vérit la
brigade du développement qui aurait dû
succéder et non pas laisser cette image
d'une France uniquement avec des soldats
robocops qui étaient dans les villages
et qui finissaient par être un peu
provoquant si je peux me permettre alors
je voudrais quand même comprendre un peu
de temps pour parler de de des ministres
Wagner et de leur et de leur stratégie
parce que je veux j'entends vos
arguments et c'est beaucoup plus
complexe ça serait totalement ridicule
de dire ce sont les mises Wagner qui
sont à l'origine du sentiment anti
français en Afrique mais quand même il y
a Gally Bakayoko il y a il y a une
stratégie derrière
il faut aussi la comprendre c'est pour
ça que moi je n'aime pas tellement
utiliser le terme de mercenaires ou le
terme de milice d'abord parce que la
société militaire privée Wagner est un
instrument aux mains de l'État russe en
réalité il est très difficile de
démontrer la nature de ces liens et
c'est ce qui fait la force d'ailleurs de
cet acteur hybride c'est la difficulté
de le qualifier y compris d'un point de
vue juridique
mais par ailleurs la qualifier de
mercenaire ou de milice ce serait maître
uniquement l'accent sur le volet
militaire encore une fois de ce cette
société or bien sûr qu'il y a des
soldats sur le terrain qui s'illustrent
en réalité de manière à ces piètres
aussi parce que la sécurité en effet non
seulement ne faiblit pas mais il y a
aussi de très graves accusations
d'exaction contre ce groupe et
d'alliance c'est très intéressant avec
non seulement l'armée mais aussi avec
les milices d'autodéfense pour le coup
national local dans le centre du Mali
donc les choses serait grave mais il y a
aussi et surtout cette stratégie de
pénétration des médias cette stratégie
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux dont on
parle et cette stratégie de réactivation
d'anciens réseaux physiques cette
fois-ci fondée sur ce qu'était
le dispositif mis en place à l'époque de
la
pour ça que voir en la Russie un nouvel
acteur et oublier ce qu'elle a été
jusque là on vient encore d'apprendre
que dans l'armée malienne on vient de
changer tous les chefs d'état-major hier
et évidemment un certain nombre sont
russophone ils n'ont pas appris le russe
en deux ans ce sont des des personnes
qui connaissent très bien cet état
depuis très longtemps il ne s'agit
évidemment pas d'une irruption de la
Russie sur la scène africaine mais d'un
retour en réactivant de vue réseau
pourtant un simple exemple le Premier
ministre en titre de la jinte Malienne a
vécu 10 ans en Union soviétique et
diplômée de l'Institut de
télécommunication de Moscou
s'agissant de la partie je dirais non
militaire dès 2018 j'avais consacré dans
l'Express une longue enquête
à la République centrafricaine tête de
pont de ce retour en force de la Russie
et indépendamment de la fourniture
d'armement à ville prix épaulé
d'ailleurs par la France qui très
maladroitement avait permis une
dérogation au niveau de conseil de
sécurité pour lever un embargo encore
bravo là aussi dans la lucidité
géopolitique on a fait très fort vous
avez eu toute une série d'initiatives
dites de soft power donc de pouvoir
d'influence je me souviens par exemple
de Miss Bangui 2018-2019 financé par une
société contrôlée par Afghani privé le
fondateur de Wagner j'ai des amis
journalistes centrafricains qui m'ont
expliqué les offres qui leur ont été
faites et qui m'ont aussi donné le tarif
d'un édito anti-français ou d'un
reportage à la gloire d'une initiative
de l'ambassade de Russie à Bangui donc
et si vous voulez
les réseaux sociaux c'est une caisse de
résonance qui permet qui surfe aussi sur
le complotisme qui existent partout qui
existent aussi qu'on a vu quand même
c'est il faut pas oublier de le dire une
insulte à l'intelligence des peuples
d'Afrique c'est tellement qu'il est il
est maître là ou si vous voulez
la riposte mon avis a été trop tardive
il peut être lié aussi à la guerre en
Ukraine écouter ce que disait Pascal
osseur directeur général de la Fondation
Méditerranée d'études stratégiques
auditionner la semaine dernière par
votre commission la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées du Sénat on l'écoute
finalement l'Afrique pour finir sur
cette partie géopolitique c'est le front
indirect de la guerre du crâne et si les
choses tournent mal
pour les Russes pour Poutine en Ukraine
il serait absolument pas surprenant de
voir de plus en plus d'activisme
anti-français anti-européen enfin il se
trouve que les Français sont les
européens les plus présents en Afrique
sur ce flanc sud Christian Cambon c'est
est-ce que c'est une sorte de guerre par
procuration que la Russie via les
ministres Wagner nous livrent en Afrique
oui bien sûr parce que la guerre que
mène la Russie contre l'Ukraine ce n'est
plus simplement contre l'Ukraine c'est
contre l'Occident contre les valeurs de
l'Occident qu'est-ce que tu qu'est-ce
que Poutine a reproché à l'Ukraine c'est
de vouloir vivre avec les valeurs de
l'Occident la démocratie les libertés et
Poutine ne peut pas ne peut pas
l'accepter à sa frontière donc il
déporte ce combat sur un continent qui
est un qui est un défi pour tout le
monde en termes d'influence on voit
d'autres pays ça a été évoqué et donc il
est tout à fait compréhensible même si
c'est tout à fait critiquable de voir la
Russie s'attaquer à nos intérêts je
pense que c'est un combat mais avec un
certain nombre de conséquences car la
France a quand même beaucoup aidé
des pays comme le Mali je rappelle que
c'est 100 millions chaque année depuis
2013 d'aide et même au moment où nous
sommes partis nous continuons de l'aide
humanitaire dans ce pays donc je suis
pas certain que Wagner sous forme de
milice ou d'organisation
continuera cette action et je pense
qu'il y aura un jour ou un autre de la
part des dirigeants africains a tiré les
conséquences de le changement
anti-français sont beaucoup dans les
concentrés dans les milieux urbains et
sur les réseaux mais dans les campagnes
les choses sont sensiblement différentes
mais effectivement comment elles sont
reçues
parce que les films sont tellement
caricaturaux quelle est la part de
de prise de conscience de la part de de
ceux qui les regardent de tomber dans
une manipulation et et de la même façon
enfin c'est ce que vous disiez faire
appel aux alors moi je continue de les
appeler les milices Wagner voilà
c'est un pouvoir occupant qui en
remplaçante si on reprend la rhétorique
alors il y a plusieurs types de
réactions comme vous le dites dans les
zones périphériques mais c'est pas la
préoccupation des populations
sincèrement
comprise pour cible à la fois par les
groupes djihadistes par les milices
d'autodéfense par les forces armées
nationales ou étrangères dans certains
cas les populations saliennes donc
franchement l'influence de la Russie ou
de la France c'est pas leur
préoccupation majeure après je pense
qu'on se rend pas compte de ce que
pensent la majorité pour la majorité
de l'opinion publique à mon avis il y a
un échec collectif y compris des
politiques de développement et c'est
très important de le dire aussi y
compris des normes vous parlez de ce
combat qui portait par la Russie c'est
très important de voir que c'est
peut-être là qui porte le plus c'est à
dire qu'il y a un conservatisme qui est
en train de se développer sur le
continent africain à la fois à travers
des acteurs civils à travers des acteurs
religieux on parle on pense beaucoup aux
acteurs musulmans mais le rôle sur le
continent aujourd'hui des églises
évangéliques par exemple explique que
toutes les politiques en termes de genre
de promotion de l'égalité hommes femmes
des LGBTQ etc est extrêmement mal perçu
sur le continent et c'est dans ce cadre
là que la voix de des puissances
conservatrices à la tête desquelles on
peut passer la Russie porte énormément
ça oui la caisse de résonance est
extrêmement forte Vincent quelques
minutes le temps à filer très vite mais
on a été plutôt globalement très
critique quand même si on doit esquisser
des solutions
alors solution à court terme il n'y en a
pas ou si je la trouve j'ai droit au
prix Nobel de la paix la semaine
prochaine parce que précisément le mal
et c'est ce qu'on a essayé de trop
progresser bien de loin d'accord juste
petite parenthèse on dénonce le
caractère milicien de Wagner la France a
un passé barbouzar en Afrique enfin à ma
connaissance Bob Denner n'est pas né à
irkouts enfin fond de la Sibérie bon et
on a utilisé des forces occultes pour
les basses BES de la République bon donc
ça c'est aussi quelque chose qui nous
revient au boomerang aujourd'hui
donc ça veut dire que le discours la
simple rhétorique sur nous avons tourné
la page nous allons engager de nouveaux
partenariats il tourne à vide il ne se
fait pas dans le discours il ne se fait
pas dans le verbe il doit se faire dans
les axes c'est-à-dire qu'il faut une
posture qui soit plus discrète plus
modeste plus humble on cesse de donner
des sons de morale comme le jeune
Emmanuel Macron l'a fait et plusieurs
chefs d'État africains me l'ont dit en
privé il est très brillant votre
président simplement il faudrait qu'il
arrête de nous convoquer pour nous
administrer des leçons de pertinence
politique bon
exemple c'est un excellent exemple il y
en a eu d'autres donc si vous voulez
imaginez que l'on puisse reconquérir les
cœurs les âmes et les esprits simplement
par un affichage rhétorique est une
chimère absolue il faut le prouver dans
les actes et encore une fois sur un
registre pratique concret mod local et
un mode conclusion parler de
développement c'est peut-être levier le
plus important à améliorer ou à
réactiver parler de développement
certainement par une réappréciation d'un
certain nombre de problèmes je lisais en
venant le déclaration du président
Bassou midi écoutez vous êtes dans quel
pays pardon Niger merci vous êtes les
Occidentaux vous êtes très gentil de
nous demander de diminuer nos
consommations de de produits
énergétiques alors de deux choses l'une
ou bien vous réinvestissez massivement
sur les énergies renouvelables au profit
de l'Afrique auquel cas vous devenez
crédible sinon c'est quand même pas
l'Afrique qui a mis le monde dans cet
état voilà des sujets concrets le climat
s'en est un qui est Dieu sait si
l'Afrique payant un prix très cher voilà
un très bon sujet sur lequel on peut se
réinvestir et poser des actes merci
beaucoup merci à tous c'était
passionnant je vais rappeler Vincent
Hugo le titre de votre livre tirant
d'Afrique les mystères du despotisme
post colonial qui est publié aux
éditions
Perrin voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro
de sciences publiques un grand merci à
toutes les équipes de Public Sénat c'est
un bonheur de travailler avec vous je
vous dis à lundi et puis demain votre
prochain rendez-vous politique sur notre
antenne la matinale Oriane Mancini qui
reçoit Jean-Claude Mailly l'ancien
secrétaire général de Force Ouvrière
belle soirée